Hallo, ich bin Haider Adamson, willkommen zurück zu
Denkerinnen in der Antike und im
Mittelalter. Dies ist die neunte Vorlesung
, in der es um Katharina von Siena und
hauptsächlich um Julian von Norwich geht. Dies sind also
zwei Denker
des 14. Jahrhunderts, die wir bereits zuletzt ins 14. Jahrhundert eingeschlichen haben  Zeit
mit Murray Poet und jetzt sind wir tatsächlich
in der Mitte und Ende des 14.
Jahrhunderts mit diesen beiden Denkern,
Sie haben wahrscheinlich Julian von
Norwich gehört, eine der berühmtesten Frauen
des Mittelalters und tatsächlich ihr Buch der
Vorführungen  ist das erste Werk in englischer Sprache
, von dem wir wissen, dass es von einer
Autorin geschrieben wurde, also ist es ein ziemlich aufregender
Text, und wir werden
später in dieser Vorlesung darauf eingehen. Zuerst werde
ich Ihnen etwas über Katharina
von Siena erzählen  etwas früherer denker,
der natürlich aus italien kommt, sie
haben gemeinsam, dass sie beide
in der volkssprache oder eigentlich in zwei
verschiedenen volkssprachen schreiben, mit anderen
worten, einer von ihnen schrieb auf lateinisch
und natürlich  se, das setzt ein Thema fort
, das uns schon in den
letzten Vorlesungen begleitet hat, wir haben gesehen, dass Hildegard
auf Latein schrieb, aber dann mit Metall und hatte eine
Hündin, Mitte des dreizehnten
Jahrhunderts hatten wir Text auf Deutsch und Niederländisch
und das letzte Mal mit Margarete wir  hatte einen
Text auf Französisch, also vervollständigen wir jetzt fast
unsere Sammlung europäischer
Sprachen, die wir mit Autoren haben,
die auf Italienisch und natürlich auf Englisch schreiben,
also haben sie das gemeinsam und
sie haben es auch gemeinsam, wie Sie sehen
werden  Es gibt einige mathematische Parallelen
zwischen den Werken von Katherine in Toulon,
insbesondere interessieren sie sich beide sehr
für das Phänomen des Leidens und dafür, wie
menschliches Leiden uns mit dem Leiden Christi in Verbindung bringen kann,
also in gewisser Weise mit dem
Leiden Gottes selbst, als er war
als Mann inkarniert, und wir
werden ein wenig darüber sprechen, wo das
mit der Tatsache zu tun haben könnte, dass
dies weibliche Autoren waren, also haben sie
einige Dinge gemeinsam, aber etwas anderes
, das ich habe  Ich habe in dieser Vortragsreihe immer wieder betont,
dass diese
Denkerinnen oft so viel Trennendes oder
so viel Gemeinsames haben, was sie kontrastiert,
und wir sollten nicht
in die Falle tappen, zu denken, dass all
diese Frauen irgendwie einfach in die Falle
gehen werden  gleiche Muster oder Gedanken oder
repräsentieren die gleiche Art von Ideen,
nur weil sie Frauen sind oder nur
weil sie weibliche Mystiker sind oder sogar
weil sie weibliche mittelalterliche christliche
Mystiker sind, obwohl wir vielleicht
bestimmte Resonanzen zwischen sagen wir über die sehen
Muslimischer Mystiker, über den wir vor ein paar
Vorträgen gesprochen haben, und ich bin ein Christ oder
vielleicht ein einheimischer christlicher Mystiker, über den wir
in letzter Zeit gesprochen haben, wir
sollten uns auch immer um den
spezifischen historischen Kontext jedes
Denkers kümmern, und das ist hier sehr wohl der Fall
, weil  Tatsächlich hatten Katharina von Siena
und Julian von Norden sehr unterschiedliche
Leben, also war Katharina von Siena
vor allem extrem politisch engagiert, sie
war so etwas wie ein Weil  Sie würde
fast sagen, eine öffentliche Intellektuelle oder
bekannt als eine Art moralisch aufrichtige
Figur, die für ihre rigorose Askese sehr bewundert wird,
und sie bewegte sich in ziemlich
erhabenen Kreisen, also gibt es eine Geschichte darüber, dass
sie sogar den Papst traf und sie
den Papst nicht traf, um seinen zu erschüttern  Hand und
irgendwie seinen Segen bekommen, wen sie mit
dem Papst trifft, um ihn
unverblümt für die Art von Vulgarität
und Korruption zu kritisieren, die sie an
der päpstlichen Kurie sieht, und das war typisch für
sie, sie war sehr kritisch gegenüber vielem,
was vor sich ging  zu ihrer Zeit die Korruption
in der Kirche und insbesondere
etwas, worüber sie sich
wie viele andere Menschen zu dieser Zeit sehr aufregte,
war das Schisma im Papsttum, mit anderen
Worten, wo Sie mehr als einen rivalisierenden
Papst haben, haben Sie einen Papst  Rom, Sie haben einen
anderen Papst in Avignon, und sie war
zu dieser Zeit eine von mehreren Intellektuellen, die
sich bemühten, zur Lösung dieses Schismas beizutragen, indem sie sich
darüber beklagten und
versuchten, die Machthaber zu ermahnen
Beenden Sie das Schisma, das natürlich
aus der Sicht frommer mittelalterlicher Menschen als sehr schädlich angesehen wurde
oder
Typ
zu folgen, also ist sie sehr politisch
engagiert,
während Julian ein sogenannter Banker ist,
also hat sie sich aus der Gesellschaft zurückgezogen,
sie lebt alleine in Norwich, wir
wissen eigentlich nicht viel über sie,
aber es gibt Aufzeichnungen über Leute, die ihr
Geld gespendet haben  zu ihrer Art von
Wohnort, die zeigt, dass sie
definitiv in Norwich gelebt hat, aber wir
kennen ihren Hintergrund nicht, wir nahmen an,
dass sie wohlhabend war, weil sie
belesen ist, also hat sie noch ziemlich
viel Ahnung  der mittelalterlichen
Geistesgeschichte und Literatur, und dieses Streben setzt
zumindest
im späteren Teil ihres Lebens ein gewisses Maß an Alphabetisierung voraus, wenn
das der Teil ihres Lebens ist, aus dem das Buch
stammt, das sie uns zeigen, also erzählen sie
wahrscheinlich sehr unterschiedliche Leben
a  Und die andere Sache ist, dass, obwohl
sie beide über das Leiden sprechen,
Katharina von Siena dem
Leiden in uns und der Askese in einer
Weise gewidmet ist, die Julian einfach nicht ist, und wenn ich
höre, erinnern wir uns vielleicht wieder an den Finger, auf den wir
letztes Mal Mutter a geschaut haben  die Dichterin,
weil sie, wie Sie sich vielleicht erinnern,
die Idee vertrat, dass eine mystische Vereinigung
mit Gott Sie tatsächlich über
die Sphäre dessen hinaustragen kann, was sie Tugend nannte, also
dachte sie, dass Sie sich über die
Sorgen der Tugend erheben können, um
sich ausschließlich der Liebe zu widmen  Gott, und es ist
nicht so klar, was sie mit Tugend im Sinn hatte,
aber eine Sache, die ich
und andere vorgeschlagen haben, ist, dass
sie mit Tugend in erster Linie Askese meint,
also Selbstbeherrschung, vielleicht Keuschheit, ein
Leben zu führen, das mehr als Mäßigung, sondern
tatsächlich Selbstverleugnung ist
und Katharina von Siena lebte
genau so ein Leben, also ist sie
tatsächlich dafür berühmt
, dass sie besonders auf Essen verzichtet, tatsächlich
scheint sie an Hunger gestorben zu sein
es gibt Geschichten darüber,
dass sie in völlig abgemagertem Zustand in ihrem Bett gepflegt wurde,
es gab Geschichten darüber, dass sie
sich tagelang ernährte,
nichts als die Eucharistie, also die Hostie
, die Sie in der Messe einnehmen, genau so, wie sie
isst  Nichts als dass
tagelang nicht sehr nahrhaft ist es ist nicht
körperlich nahrhaft Opiat vielleicht
spirituell nahrhaft und das hat
tatsächlich viel Aufmerksamkeit in der
Literatur über Katharina von
Siena sowohl damals als auch
heute auf sich gezogen  Ein wichtiges Buch
über mittelalterliche Mystiker, insbesondere weibliche
Mystiker, von jemandem in Caroline Bynum, in
dem sie über die intensive
besondere Beziehung spricht, die diese weiblichen
Figuren zum Essen haben, also handelt es sich hier um eine sehr,
sehr tiefe thematische Dachbodensymbolik,
wenn Sie darüber nachdenken in gewisser Weise  Die
zentrale Doktrin des Christentums ist, dass
Gott als Mensch inkarniert ist und dass dieser
Mensch seinen Körper für dich hingibt
und geopfert wird  Für Sie die Art und Weise, wie ein
Opfertier in der jüdischen Tradition in
gewissem Sinne geopfert worden sein könnte, und das ist es natürlich, was
im Sakrament der Eucharistie symbolisiert wird,
dass Sie tatsächlich das
Fleisch Christi essen, indem Sie sich so sehr
auf das Essen von Menschen wie Katharina von konzentrieren
Siena lenkte die Aufmerksamkeit auf diese
Körperlichkeit der christlichen Theologie und
insbesondere auf die Körperlichkeit der
Eucharistie selbst, so dass es nicht nur eine
Art zufällige Entscheidung für sie ist
, nichts als die Eucharistie zu essen, die sie
sozusagen ist, sondern indem sie das tut, zeigt sie,
wie hingebungsvoll sie ist  zu diesem zentralen
Symbol der Körperlichkeit der
christlichen theologischen Doktrin und
viele Leute würden meiner Meinung nach sagen wollen, dass
dies ein charakteristisches Merkmal
speziell weiblicher Mystiker ist.
Vielleicht gibt es eine Minderheit, dies ist ein
bisschen sexistisch, aber natürlich ist es
eine  sexistische Idee, die die Frauen selbst
irgendwie von ihrer Gesellschaft übernommen haben könnten,
also wäre die Idee, dass
Frauen mehr sind  Mit dem Körper verbundene
Männer sind eher mit dem Geist verbunden,
also haben Sie sozusagen lateinisch-scholastische
Philosophen, die das Leben des Geistes
und der Universität leben, und dann haben Sie
diese etwas abtrünnigen Frauen, die
außerhalb des üblichen institutionellen Kontextes leben,
besonders im Fall von jemandem wie
Julian, die ein viel intimeres
Bewusstsein für ihren Körper haben und
ihren Körper als eine Art Nexus für die
Begegnung mit Göttern Gottes benutzen, kommen ihnen in
körperlicher Form buchstäblich in Form von
Nahrung entgegen, im Falle der Eucharistie sehen sie
auch Christus lebendig  physische Form, das werden
wir später bei Julian sehen, und
das ist alles eine Art für sie,
über die Bedeutung der christlichen Spiritualität nachzudenken,
was damals als ein unverwechselbares Blatt angesehen werden könnte, wenn
Sie eine weibliche Art haben. Ich bin ein  ein bisschen
skeptisch, wie Sie vielleicht
schon erraten haben, da wir oft sehen,
welche Verallgemeinerungen über die weiblichen
Mystiker des Mittelalters
dieselben Themen in männlichen mystischen
Aut finden  hors der Zeit und sogar nicht
mystische Autoren der Zeit, also ist es nicht
so, dass alle Männer im
Mittelalter einfach die Tatsache übersehen haben, dass es im
Christentum um Körperlichkeit geht, es geht
darum, dass Gott Fleisch wird, was
offensichtlich grundlegend für die gesamte
Theologie der Zeit ist und wenn  Sie
suchen nach Literatur,
die diese Körperlichkeit wirklich betont, Sie können
sie auch bei männlichen Autoren finden, aber es war
immer noch zuzugeben, dass es ein sehr auffälliges
Merkmal vieler Figuren ist, die wir
uns angesehen haben, und es taucht auf verschiedene
Weise bei Kathleen auf  so auftaucht
, dass es in ihrem Fall bei manchen anderen Beamten um Essen und Essen bzw. Nichtessen zu gehen scheint,
und beim Betrachten zeigt sich in
Blick auf die erotischen Bilder und erotischen
Themen übernommene Themen und Tropen
höfische Liebesliteratur und das
wäre eine andere Art, darüber nachzudenken
,
eine dritte Art, die auftaucht, ist das Verweilen
auf dem Konzept der Mutterschaft, also der
Beziehung zwischen Mutter und
Kind  d, wie es kommen wird, sehr
stark und Julian, aber bevor wir
zu Julian kommen, sprechen wir ein bisschen mehr
über Katharina von Siena und schauen uns
einige Passagen aus einem ihrer Werke an. Dies
ist ein Brief mit dem
Titel Providence, der tatsächlich geschrieben wurde
auf Italienisch, und ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein Zitat
daraus geben.
Unendlicher Kummer, den ich meiner Kreatur
auf zwei Arten wünsche, also spricht offensichtlich Gott
und sie bringt Gott auf eine Art zum Ausdruck
, durch ihre Trauer um ihren eigenen
Verstand, den er gegen mich begangen hat
ihr Schöpfer andererseits durch ihre
Trauer über die Sünden, die er ihre
Nachbarn an mir begangen sieht, von
solchen, insofern sie
unendliche Begierde haben, die mit mir verbunden ist
durch eine Zuneigung der Liebe und daher
betrübt sind, wenn sie mich beleidigt haben  oder sieh mich
beleidigt jeden Schmerz, ob
geistig oder körperlich, woher auch immer
es kommen mag, unendliches Verdienst erhalten hat und
für eine Schuld gesättigt ist, die eine unendliche Strafe verdient hat,
obwohl ihre
Werke endlich und endlich sind  e in endlicher Zeit,
aber insofern sie die Tugend des
Verlangens besitzen und ihr Leiden mit
Verlangen und Reue und unendlicher
Unlust gegen ihre Schuld ertragen, wird ihr
Schmerz als würdig erachtet, und ein weiterer Text, der
sehr angenehm ist, liebste Tochter zu treffen,
ist das bereitwillige Verlangen, alles zu ertragen  Schmerz
und Erschöpfung bis zum Tod für die
Erlösung der Seelen, denn je mehr die
Zylinder, desto mehr zeigt sie, dass sie
mich liebt,
also ist dies wieder etwas, das wir hatten,
bevor wir uns vor allem auf die bettelnden
Mystiker des 13. Jahrhunderts, Huh de Vich
und Mechtogan, einließen  Marktarbeit seine Idee, dass
man Gott am nächsten kommt, indem man
wieder mit dem Leiden in Berührung kommt. Ein Teil der
Idee hier ist, dass Christus für uns gelitten hat
und wir uns mit Christus identifizieren, indem wir,
glaube ich, den Wunsch haben, zu leiden und dann zu
leiden oder zumindest geduldig zu ertragen
das Leiden, das auf uns zukommt,
aber was Katharina von Siena hier sagt
, ist nicht nur gut, wenn Sie Glück haben, werden
Sie nicht leiden, aber wenn Sie es tun, dann
gehen Sie damit um, damit es nicht l ist  wie eine Art
stoischer Philosophie, wo du einfach nimmst,
was kommt, und du geduldig erträgst, wenn
Leiden dein Schicksal ist,
nein, sie scheint tatsächlich vorzuschlagen,
dass du das Leiden bewusst suchen solltest, um dich
mit Gott zu identifizieren,
also ist ein Teil dessen, was hier vor sich geht  eine
kleine Art von Demütigung, so
dass man erkennt, dass man es verdient zu leiden, weil
man demütig ist, dass man unvollkommen ist, dass man
sündig ist, und Teil der Idee ist diese
Vorstellung von Leiden um Gottes willen
und Leiden als Identifikation mit
Christus, so scheint es  eine sehr
pessimistische Lehre zu sein, und ich denke, dass
dieser Eindruck durch
die nächste Passage, die ich Ihnen vorlesen möchte, nicht wirklich gemindert wird, in
der es um das Konzept der Sinnlichkeit geht
, also um die Art der niederen
Begierden, die in der menschlichen Natur in Ordnung sind, so sie  sagt,
wenn die Seele sich selbst kennt, findet sie
Demut und Hass ihrer eigenen sinnlichen
Leidenschaft, denn sie lernt das perverse Gesetz kennen,
das in ihren Gliedern gebunden ist und
das gegen den Geist ankämpft
Deshalb erhebt sie sich mit Hass auf ihre eigene
Sinnlichkeit und zerquetscht sie mit großer Ernsthaftigkeit unter der Ferse der
Vernunft. Sie
entdeckt in sich selbst die Fülle meiner
Güte, also gefällt
mir an dieser Passage wirklich, dass ein Verdacht untergraben wird
, den viele Menschen
gegenüber diesen mittelalterlichen haben  Mystiker, das heißt
, sie sind alle irrational, also wollen sie, dass
wir die Vernunft loswerden, über die Vernunft hinausgehen, uns
stattdessen auf einige mystische
Reflexionen einlassen, direktes Bewusstsein von Gott,
direkte Erfahrung von Gott und so weiter, und
obwohl das manchmal wahr sein kann, haben
wir  Tatsächlich sahen wir, dass
Vernunft bei diesen Autoren normalerweise sehr
positiv auftaucht, also sahen wir sie
positiv, wenn auch nicht so
ausreichend am Anfang, und wir sahen auch bei
Marguerite Perret,
wo eine Vernunft eine sehr
interessante Figur war, die drängte
sich gegen die gewagten Lehren der
Liebe zu wehren, schien sich aber auch
von der Liebe überzeugen zu lassen, dass die
Sichtweise der Liebe einiges
zu bieten hat, so ist es oft  Begriffe
als eine Art eingeschränkte Perspektive, aber
immer noch eine wertvolle Perspektive, hier
wird dagegen die Vernunft den
niederen Begierden der Seele gegenübergestellt, Sinnlichkeit und
Katharina klingt hier nach nichts so
sehr wie nach einem Plattenbegehren, wenn wir also
bis zu Platon zurückdenken  Denken Sie zurück an
die Republik, über die wir vor langer
Zeit in einem der ersten Vorträge gesprochen haben, als wir Platon sahen, wie er davon
sprach, dass die Seele mehr
als einen Teil hat und der rationale
Teil der Seele den Rest der Seele beherrschen muss
und Frauen natürlich einen
rationalen Teil haben müssen  Teil können sie ihren
rationalen Teil verwirklichen, deshalb dachte er, dass
sie Philosophen sein könnten, und das ist eine
Idee,
die im Rest
der Geschichte der antiken Philosophie von uns
allen aufgegriffen und erweitert wird, insbesondere in der Spätantike, als der
Platonismus eine dominierende Schule ist  des
Denkens und des Platonismus kommt es in
die christlich-ästhetische Bewegung, die
in der Spätantike offenbar
nach dem Aufkommen des Christentums so erblüht
sind diese Wüstenväter und -mütter
, die ich schon erwähnt habe, die wegziehen
und in einer Zelle oder in einer Höhle leben, vielleicht
nicht viel essen, sich vielleicht sogar
zu Tode fangen, wie es Halfmann getan hat,
und die Art von Ideologie, die meiner Meinung nach
nicht wäre  Ein zu starkes Wort ist, dass Sie
als Mensch eine Art zweifaches Sein sind.
Sie sind ein rationales Wesen. Sie haben auch einen niedrigeren
Aspekt, den sinnlichen Teil, der körperliche
Wünsche, Verlangen nach Sex, Essen und Trinken hat,
und Ihre Aufgabe ist es, diesen niedrigeren zu unterdrücken
Teil und mach es so schwach wie möglich,
also unterwerfe es deiner Vernunft, jetzt ist es
sehr klar, dass Plato nicht dachte, dass
dies bedeutet, in die Wüste zu gehen und
dich zu Tode zu hungern, denn obwohl
das Ziel
einfach ist, mit dem Verlangen zu kämpfen, ist das
nicht das Richtige  Er dachte überhaupt, tatsächlich gibt
es Passagen in Plato, wo
er über die Bedeutung eines
starken, gesunden Körpers und eines starken,
gesunden Geistes spricht, und er sagt,
dass das Schlimmste ist, wenn deine
Seele zu mächtig für deinen Körper oder deinen ist
Körper  y ist zu groß für deine Seele,
während Catherine eher der Ansicht zu sein scheint,
dass ich sagen würde, der spätantike
Platanus und insbesondere der spätantike
christliche Plattennebel
, dass du wirklich versuchen solltest
, deine Wünsche so weit wie
möglich zu minimieren und  Sie kann es nicht, da man
sich des Verlangens nicht vollständig entledigen kann, man muss
nur gegen sie kämpfen, und sie hat
offensichtlich gegen ihr eigenes Verlangen
nach Essen Krieg geführt und diesen Kampf so weit gewonnen
, dass er sie tatsächlich umgebracht hat
etwas anderes, womit ich denke, dass es damit zusammenhängt
Dies ist ein Thema, das ich bereits
zuvor erwähnt habe, nämlich der Begriff der Demut,
also die Art von Krieg gegen sich selbst. Dann
kennen Sie eine negative Einstellung zu sich selbst
, die alles, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
zumindest gegenüber dem unteren Teil von sich
selbst mit Hass oder Hass zu tun hat  gibt Ihnen einen
Grund, sich auf diese Verhaltensweisen der
Selbstverleugnung einzulassen,
und das passt offensichtlich sehr gut zu
der Idee, eine sehr bescheidene
Einschätzung Ihres eigenen Wertes zu haben, und das ist
etwas, das kommt  ziemlich stark
und andere Pepin und andere Passagen aus
diesem Brief, den sie über die Vorsehung geschrieben hat, also
hier ist es in der Selbsterkenntnis
, dass Sie sich demütigen werden, wenn Sie sehen, dass Sie in sich
selbst nicht einmal für Ihr Wesen existieren
, wie Sie lernen werden, da es von
mir stammt  Ich habe sowohl Sie als auch andere geliebt,
bevor Sie existierten, also
haben wir hier eigentlich eine ziemlich gemeinsame
Vorstellung, dass Sie tatsächlich viele mittelalterliche
Denker gesehen haben, einschließlich scholastischer
Philosophen, was bedeutet, dass in gewissem Sinne
alles, was Gott erschafft, schon immer
existiert hat  Gott vielleicht in Form von
göttlichen Ideen, die wie
photonische Formen sein könnten, oder vielleicht existieren sogar Individuen
irgendwie in Gott und manifestieren
sich dann in der physischen Realität. Sie
geht hier nicht wirklich ins Detail,
aber ich denke, ihr Punkt ist ein Punkt, den
Sie verstehen  In vielen mystischen
Autoren heißt das, dass das einzige Ausmaß, in dem
Sie als Geldbeutel
real sind, das Ausmaß ist, in dem Sie bereits in Gott real sind,
so dass Sie in Gottes Macht oder
Wissen wohnen  oder kreative Energie, wie auch immer
Sie es nennen wollen, auf dieser Ebene ist
Ihre reale, physische Art und Weise, Ihre
Stationsmanifestation ist wirklich nichts, vielleicht sind Sie
es nicht wirklich, und wenn Sie es sind, dann
sind Sie nichts, was real ist,
etwas, das Sie im Sufismus sehen, es ist
etwas Sie  Sehen Sie in Latein das mittelalterliche
Christentum und Sie sehen es hier in
Catherine, und ich denke, wir könnten
das alles zusammenbringen, indem wir vorschlagen,
dass der höhere Teil von Ihnen der Teil
von Ihnen ist, der Gott am nächsten ist, so dass
dies für die Realität wahr ist, die Sie
wirklich besitzen  mit und in gott und
dein unterer aspekt ist eher der erschaffene
physische aspekt und das ist der aspekt
, mit dem du kämpfen und kämpfen musst.
ich denke, es ist fair zu sagen,
dass zumindest diese abhandlung, ich meine
catherine, auch andere werke geschrieben hat und
sie ist  Eine komplizierte Figur, aber ich denke,
es wäre fair zu sagen, dass die
Vorsehung in gewisser Weise a, wie ich schon sagte, eine
sehr negative oder pessimistische
Anthropologie hat, zumindest was die
gesamte Person betrifft, also b  oth der Körper und die Seele
oder der Körper und der Geist der Person, natürlich
könnte man das anders drehen und sagen,
nein, sie hat eine sehr optimistische
Anthropologie, denn das wahre Du ist das
Du, das mit Gott in Kontakt steht, und deshalb muss
ich das nicht unbedingt haben  zu sagen, dass
sie eine so pessimistische Denkerin ist, aber sie ist
sicherlich pessimistisch, was unser
physisches Wesen betrifft, und sie scheint zu sehen, dass unser
physisches Wesen eine positive
Rolle in ihrem Denken spielt, hauptsächlich weil
es der Anblick von Leiden sein kann,
durch den Sie sich mit
Christus I identifizieren  Ich denke, wir bekommen eine ziemlich andere
Einstellung zu all dem und sicherlich
einen ganz anderen Ton bei Julian
von Norwich, der einer der
auffälligsten optimistischen Denker ist, der
wirklich im gesamten Mittelalter
auftaucht, und wahrscheinlich der optimistischste
Denker, den wir in diesem Vortrag haben  Serie,
also ist sie weder jemand, der im
Leiden schwelgt, noch ist sie jemand, der
die Idee von qualvollem, unerfülltem Verlangen
nach Gott schwelgt, was etwas ist, was wir tun  sah
bei den großen mystikern eher
jemand der eine begegnung mit gott hatte
die sie mit einer unglaublich
positiven einstellung zu sich selbst
zu gott zu gotts verhältnis
zur welt erfüllte also hat man mit julian
wirklich jemanden der sozusagen
die leidensphase durchgemacht hat  und
Angst und ist auf der anderen
Seite herausgekommen und nimmt jetzt eine andere
Perspektive ein, wo sie gelernt hat, dass, wie
sie bekanntlich sagt, Gott wird alles
gut machen und alles soll
gut werden, dies die berühmteste Zeile in ihrem
Buch der Showings ist, also lasst uns  Fahren Sie mit
Julians Werken fort. Sie sind eigentlich zwei
Dinge, die sie geschrieben hat, eine Art
Kurzversion des Textes, den sie uns anbietet,
und dann eine viel längere Version,
die zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten geschrieben wurden. Es
scheint also, dass sie
eine hatte  Vision oder eine Reihe von Visionen, während
sie krank war, also erzählt sie uns, dass sie
tatsächlich darum gebetet hat, dass eine Krankheit
zu ihrem Vater geschickt wird, über Schattierungen der
Catharine-Einstellung, richtig, ich will, ich
will leiden damit ich gott näher sein kann
also betet sie für eine krankheit und sie bekommt
was sie wollte also liegt sie in ihrem
bett vielleicht sogar kurz vor dem tod und
dann schaut sie hoch zu einem kruzifix
so quer über eine christusstatue  das Kreuz,
und sie hat diese lebhafte Vision mit
Blut, und es ist sehr, sehr konkret und
fleischlich, und das ist nur eine von einer Reihe
von Visionen, die sie hat, also wissen alle, dass
sie fast wie Halluzinationen klingen
, die sie hatte, als sie in dieser
Art von Fieber war  Traumzustand und dann,
als sie endeten, wusste sie nicht, was
sie davon halten sollte, und tatsächlich erzählt sie uns,
dass sie mit einem Priester darüber gesprochen und
gesagt hat, oh, Sie können das ignorieren, das waren
bloße Ausschweifungen, und sie
geißelt sich später irgendwie dafür  Wenn man die
Wichtigkeit dieser Vision herunterspielt, dass sie
von Gott war, und sie beginnt, sie als
wirklich etwas zu betrachten, das wirklich einen tiefen
Einblick in die Natur Gottes und in
Gottes Beziehung zu uns bietet, scheint es auch,
dass sie ein zweites r hatte  Eine Reihe von
Visionen, die ihr geholfen haben, die
Bedeutung der ersten zu verstehen, jedenfalls
schreibt sie dann ihr Buch der Vorführungen,
das eine sehr lange Abhandlung in Mittelenglisch ist,
und es ist wirklich faszinierend.
Ich habe nicht wirklich Zeit zum Reden
über all die Arten, in denen es
interessant ist, aber ich werde
einige der Themen für Sie heraussuchen und sie
durchgehen. Eine Sache, die ich jedoch erwähnen sollte,
ist, dass sie keine
einzigartige Figur in dem Sinne ist, dass sie, ich
meine, sie ist es sicherlich  eine einzigartige Figur,
aber sie ist nicht einzigartig in dem Sinne, dass
es andere wichtige Autoren gibt
, die Ende
des 14
Chaucer, Autor von The
Canterbury Tales, ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit
gibt es einen oft in William Langland,
der ein Werk mit dem Titel Piers Plowman schrieb
, ein langes Gedicht, das Dinge erzählt
, die er in einem Traum gesehen hat, es ist sehr
kritisch gegenüber der Kirche  h, es geht viel um
Moral, Anmut und so weiter, es ist ein wirklich
interessanter Text und näher an der Art
von Stil und Absicht von Julians Buch der
Shows, Sie haben andere englische Autoren
, die eine mystischere Neigung haben, also jemand
früher, Sie haben einen Autor namens Richard
Yoda und  ungefähr
zeitgleich mit Julian gibt es
andere Autoren wie Walter Hilton, einen
weiteren englischen Mystiker, dessen
Namen wir nicht kennen, der aber ein Buch mit
dem Titel The Cloud of Unknowing geschrieben hat, das eine
Art klassisches Werk über Spiritualität und
Mystik ist,
also nehmen Sie diese  alles zusammen, also wenn man
diese Autoren einfach nimmt, also Royalton,
der Autor der Wolke des Unwissens, und
Julian von Norwich, dann hat man eine Gruppe von
Autoren, die manchmal
als eine Art Bewegung zusammengenommen werden, manchmal
nennen die Leute sie die englischen oder mittelenglischen
Mystiker und  Auch hier besteht die
Gefahr, anzunehmen, dass sie alle
dasselbe lehren, aber das ist eigentlich
nicht der Fall, die Texte sind also sehr unterschiedlich
Zum Beispiel hat die Wolke des Unwissens
nicht diese Struktur, die
uns seit Hildegard und auch von Hot
Image so vertraut geworden ist, wo Sie Visionen in der
Person haben, die die Visionen erlebt hat, die
sie nacheinander erklärt und
gewissermaßen erklärt  Bedeutung von ihnen
für Sie, also ist es nicht so, als wären sie alle nur
die gleiche Art von Text, und die Wolke des
Unwissens hat eigentlich nicht viel, ich würde
sagen, eher andere Anliegen als
Julian Jerome Ians Interesse, wie wir
sehen werden, viel mehr über das Böse  die Natur
des Bösen, seine Präsenz in der Welt, wie
Gott das Böse zulässt, wie Gott uns vom Bösen erlösen wird,
während es bei der Wolke des Unwissens viel
mehr um
Erkenntnistheorie geht, also geht es darum, wie
wir Gott kennenlernen können
Der beste Weg, Gott zu kennen, ist, diesen
Zustand des Unwissens oder Vergessens zu erreichen,
in dem alle Gedanken entfernt werden,
weil es irgendwie zu Gottes Transzendenz passt,
und das ist eine sehr typische
mystische Idee, aber i  Es ist keine Idee
, die bei Julian wirklich betont wird.
Ich denke, wenn Sie nach
Parallelen zu Julians in Bezug auf ihre
theologischen Anliegen suchen möchten, ist es vielleicht besser
, an eine weitere Gruppe von Autoren zu denken
, die zu dieser Zeit
im späten 14. Jahrhundert aktiv sind  Jahrhundert und dies sind die
Autoren, die sich um die berüchtigte
Person John Wickliffe versammelt haben, also kennen Sie vielleicht
seinen Namen, weil er mit
der ersten englischen Version der Bibel in Verbindung gebracht wird,
dieser sogenannten Wickliffe-Bibel, die
ein bisschen irreführend ist, weil er sie nicht selbst
übersetzt hat  Obwohl er
möglicherweise den Prozess der
Übersetzung geleitet hat, könnte es seine
Art von Mitarbeitern gewesen sein, die die Bibel erstellt haben,
und es war wahrscheinlich mehr als eine Person, aber
es scheint, als wäre es eine Arbeit, die über einen
langen Zeitraum von
mehreren Personen geleistet wurde  Leute, also eigentlich ist
diese Idee
, eine englische Bibel zu produzieren, schon bedeutsam, weil sie einem
zeigt, dass es in England
zu dieser Zeit eine Bewegung in Richtung individueller
Spiritualität und eines i gibt  Einzelbegegnung
mit dem Bibeltext und vielleicht auch eine
Abkehr vom Institutionellen und dem
institutionellen Rahmen der Kirche
, das trifft sicher zu, bei Wickliffe
selbst war er ein sehr engagierter
Kritiker der Kirche, der sehr unzufrieden war mit
der Tatsache, dass die Kirche so wohlhabend war
so dem materiellen Erfolg ergeben,
politisch engagiert, tat er fast so,
als wäre der Papst eine andere Art von
Kaiser mit seinen eigenen Reichsarmeen und
Landbesitz und so weiter, und er wollte, dass
die Kirche sich
wie die Apostel der Armut widmet, sagte er und führte ihn
sozusagen ein  Eine ganze Reihe von
richtiger christlichen Werten ist etwas anderes
, und das ist übrigens, dass wir
bei Julian nichts davon bekommen, aber was
wir bei Julian bekommen,
der auch im Arbeitsleben ist, ist eine
Faszination für das Problem der Gnade
und Vorherbestimmung  Wie gesagt, sie
interessiert sich wirklich für das Phänomen des
Bösen und der Sünde. Woher
kommt die Sünde? Wie reagiert Gott auf die Sünde? Wie verhält sich Gott
zu den Menschen?  le, die
trotz ihrer Sündhaftigkeit gerettet werden und wo Cliff auch
daran sehr interessiert war, führt
er die Idee ein, dass es eine
Art wahre Kirche gibt, die nicht die
institutionelle Kirche ist, sondern nur
die Kirche im Sinne aller
Menschen, die sein werden  alle
Menschen gerettet, die am Ende in den Himmel kommen werden,
und er weist darauf hin, dass
wir nicht wissen, wer diese Menschen sind, dass wir sie nicht
identifizieren können, dies wird oft als
eine Art Vorahnung oder Erwartung dessen angesehen,
was  Wir bekommen später in der protestantischen
Revolution mit Luther und Calvin
diese Idee, dass es diese
prädestinierten geretteten Auserwählten gibt,
die von uns während dieses Lebens nicht identifiziert werden können, das ist
etwas, das wir bereits in
Wickliffe finden,
und es ist etwas, das in
Julian not auftaucht  mit so viel
Sorge um das Wohlergehen, wie identifizieren wir
die Menschen, die gerettet sind, und die Menschen, die
es nicht sind, aber sie weist darauf hin, dass
es zwei Gruppen von Menschen gibt, die, die
gerettet sind, und die, die es nicht sind
Sie interessiert sich wirklich vor allem für
Gottes Beziehung zu den Menschen, die
gerettet werden, also kommen wir jetzt auf all das, aber
der Grund, warum ich es erwähne, abgesehen davon,
dass ich Ihnen nur ein bisschen historischen Kontext gebe,
ist, Sie daran zu erinnern, dass wir
historisches brauchen  Kontext wie diesen,
um jeden dieser Denker für sich zu verstehen,
also sollten wir sie, wie gesagt,
nicht einfach
alle in die große Gruppe
mystischer christlicher mittelalterlicher Autorinnen werfen, als ob
sie alle gleich wären, also hier ein
Zitat  Eigentlich geht es um Chile und es ist nicht
aus ihrem Ausstellungsbuch, sondern von
einer Gelehrten, die über die Rolle
der Körperlichkeit im Körper in ihrer Arbeit
spricht, was etwas war, was wir gesehen haben, war wichtig
und Catherine, also sagt sie, dass Julians
Krankheit eine Art Zahlungsunfähigkeit darstellt
ihr aus der starken Betonung der
Körperlichkeit können wir erkennen, dass Julian im Gegensatz zu
denen, die versuchen, dem Gefängnis des Körpers zu entkommen,
ihren Körper als den
Ort der spirituellen Erleuchtung
ansieht, also ist das hier Maria  nth und ich denke,
dass jung, was sie dort sagt, tatsächlich vermittelt,
was ich versuche, was ich
gerade erwähnt habe, nämlich dass diese
Autoren unterschiedliche Absichten und
Schlussfolgerungen haben, denn natürlich
würde man das nicht unbedingt über Katharina von Siena sagen,
also Katharina von  Siena
scheint wirklich gegen
ihren Körper zu kämpfen, während für Julian der Körper
der Weg ist, wenn das Mittel der Ort ist,
wie Nisman sagt, wo wir
Gott begegnen, und wir begegnen Gott
in erster Linie durch Leiden, also
haben wir wieder die Geschichte  über Julians
Krankheit die Visionen, die sie hatte, als
sie auf ihrem Krankenbett lag, und wie Kath,
wenn sie sich sehr für das
Phänomen des Leidens interessiert, also hier ist
etwas, was sie darüber sagt, was sie
hier sagt, ich habe ein großartiges Laufen zwischen
Christus und uns gesehen, für mein Verständnis
als er Schmerzen hatte
, leiden wir, und alle Kreaturen, die Schmerzen erleiden könnten,
haben mit ihm gelitten, das heißt, alle
Kreaturen, die Gott zu unserem
Dienst gemacht hat, die Tanne  Mament und unser Versagen für
Kummer und ihre Art in der Zeit des
Sterbens Christi. Sie könnten dies übrigens nicht tun,
weil ich viele Tippfehler übersehen habe.
Ich gebe Ihnen die ursprüngliche
Schreibweise, weil ich denke, dass sie
dem modernen Englisch nahe genug ist dass Sie '
Ich werde es verstehen können, aber ich werde nicht
versuchen, etwas daraus zu machen.
Altenglische Aussprache hier, weil ich
nicht weiß, wie, also müssen Sie einfach
mitlesen, wie ich
es vorlese  Sie, der Punkt dabei ist
wieder, dass wir das haben, was sie eine
Warnung mit Gott nennt, also bedeutet eins hier
Vereinigung, also Vereinigung mit Gott durch
Leiden, und insbesondere haben wir einen
Fokus auf das Leiden als physisches
Phänomen und die Idee der Körperlichkeit
als Ich  Ich habe gesagt, dass Julian sehr wichtig ist,
hier ist eine weitere Passage darüber, und hier wird
sie tatsächlich in dieses Thema einsteigen,
indem sie an die Jungfrau Maria denkt.
Dies ist unsere Liebe Frau, die in der ersten
Zeile erwähnt wird. Diese Muttergottes ist unsere Mutter, in der
wir sein werden  alle sind c  verloren und von ihr geboren
in Christus für sie, dass seine Mutter unseres
Retters Mutter von allem ist, was
in unserem Retter gerettet wurde, und unser Retter ist
unsere ureigene Mutter, in der wir
endlos geboren werden und niemals so
aus ihm herauskommen werden  Hier sehen wir eine andere
Dimension der Körperlichkeit von Julians Arbeit, also ist
es nicht nur die Körperlichkeit der
Visionen selbst, das Blut und das
Leiden Christi, dass sie die
Körperlichkeit seines Fleisches sieht, und so weiter, es ist
auch das Thema, das ich
vorhin erwähnt habe  ähm über Mutterschaft,
also wie ich schon sagte, sie kommt hinein, indem sie an
die Jungfrau Maria denkt, aber dann sagt sie
etwas viel Überraschenderes, nämlich
dass Christus eigentlich unsere Mutter ist, also
wäre eine Art, darüber nachzudenken,
dass die ersten beiden Personen der
Dreieinigkeit  sind Gott der Vater und Gott Sohn,
der auch unsere Mutter ist,
und tatsächlich ist dies Teil eines langen
Abschnitts des Buches der Vorstellungen, wo
sie immer wieder sagt, dass Gott
irgendwie unsere Mutter ist, dass Christus unsere
Mutter ist und  gibt uns eine ganze Reihe von
Gründen, dies zu verdünnen, also ist ein Grund,
dass Gott sich um uns kümmert und uns nährt und
uns hilft, uns in unserem Zustand
der Sünde zu pflegen, in dem wir bedürftig sind, so wie eine
Mutter sich um unser Kind kümmern würde, aber diese
Passage  Das, was ich Ihnen gerade vorgelesen habe, gibt uns eine
viel konkretere körperliche Vorstellung, und
deshalb gebe ich es als Beispiel für
ihr Interesse an Körperlichkeit,
damit sie vorschlägt, dass Christus
uns irgendwie umarmt, so wie eine Mutter
ihr Kind umarmt, wenn die
Mutter schwanger ist  Mit anderen Worten,
Sie sind in Gott oder in Christus enthalten, indem Sie
durch sie durch die
von Christus angebotene Gnade gerettet werden, so wie
unsere Mutter unser ungeborenes Kind enthält,
nachdem sie gesagt hat, dass es auch wahr ist, dass
wir in Julian ein Thema finden, das wir gefunden haben  Es ist
Katharine, was diese Vorstellung von
Sinnlichkeit ist, also der niedere Aspekt der
Seele,
und es ist nicht so, dass Sie das
Physische oder den Körper als rein
positive Vorstellung haben, und Julian, Sie haben
es auch als potenzielle Quelle der Sünde  Es ist eine
Passage über dieses Recht, da es
im unteren Teil einen tierischen Willen gibt, der
vielleicht kein gutes Recht will, also gibt es
im höheren Teil einen göttlichen Willen, der so
gut ist, dass er niemals Böses will, aber
immer gut so auf dem einen  Neben diesem
tierischen Willen ist der niedere Wille sicherlich
mit körperlichen Dingen verbunden, also ist es
unter anderem ein Wille für körperliches Vergnügen
und natürlich ein Wille für Sünde,
aber beachten Sie, dass sie nicht sagt, gut,
da ist dein Verstand, der gut ist, und
deiner, da ist dein  Körper, der schlecht ist und
sie nicht, und sie verwendet übrigens
das Wort Sinnlichkeit auch für diesen unteren Teil,
aber sie macht keine große Sache aus
dem
eeeh, und das ist etwas, was ein
Tellernest sagen könnte, dass sie es tut '  Machen Sie keine
große Sache aus der Tatsache, dass Ihr Verstand oder
Ihre Vernunft, abgesehen von Ihrem
Körper, während Ihre niedere Seele
mit Ihrem Körper verbunden
ist, nicht viel mehr zu sein schien, als dass sie in Ihrem
Verstand selbst tatsächlich in Ihrem
Willen waren, was ist  eine sehr prominente Idee  In der
Philosophie des 14. Jahrhunderts gibt es eine
Art Gabelung oder Dichotomie, also haben Sie
Ihren guten Willen und Ihren schlechten Willen, und
für sie kämpfen Sie nicht wirklich gegen Ihren
Körper, sondern gegen Ihre niedere,
kleinere Sünde und was wirklich
interessant an ihr ist  In dieser
Passage heißt es außerdem, dass der
höhere Wille nur Gutes wollen kann, also haben Sie
diese Art von zwei Trieben oder zwei
Wünschen oder zwei Willen, einer
zeigt Sie immer zum Guten, der andere
zeigt mich immer zum Schlechten, und da
Sie es haben  dieser höhere Wille zum Guten
da ist ein Teil von dir, der gewissermaßen und
das beginnt tatsächlich zu drohen
, ein bisschen ketzerisch zu klingen, dass
da ein Teil deiner Seele ist, der
von der Sünde unberührt zu sein scheint. Ich glaube, sie
würde offensichtlich sagen, oh nein  Nein, nein, du hast
auch diesen anderen Teil, der
dich zur Sünde führt, also ist es nicht so, als wärst du
jemals frei von Sünde, denn wie gesagt, das
wäre ketzerisch und eine mittelalterliche
christliche Perspektive, aber es ist immer noch
sehr s  zu glauben, dass es diese Art von
unberührtem, makellosem, perfektem Teil von dir gibt,
und wenn du dem einfach folgen könntest, dann
wärst du jetzt wieder gut. Es wäre
ketzerisch zu sagen, dass du dem einfach
folgen oder die ganze Zeit deinen guten Willen
ohne Gottes wählen kannst  Hilfe
, die Pelagianische Häresie genannt wird und
bereits von Agustin und der Spätantike widerlegt wurde,
aber Julian
glaubt das nicht, aber es bedeutet, dass es für
Julian einen sehr natürlichen
Weg für Gott gibt, uns bei allem, was Gott
zu tun hat, zu helfen  Das stärkt irgendwie unsere
Verbindung zum Guten,
unser Engagement für das Wohlwollen, und
tatsächlich hat sie, wie ich schon sagte,
eine sehr auffallend optimistische Einstellung
gegenüber Gottes Beziehung zu uns, und
dies scheint direkt aus etwas zu stammen, in dem
sie Erfahrungen gemacht hat  ihre Visionen
, nämlich diese Sache mit Gott, der ihr verspricht,
dass alles gut werden wird, also
hier ist eine Passage, die ausdrückt,
wie optimistisch sie sein kann. Ich habe Gott in einem
Punkt gesehen, das heißt in meinem Verständnis
Bei diesem Anblick sah ich, dass er in allen
Dingen ist. Ich sah wirklich, dass Gott
alles tut, sei es noch nie so wenig, und ich
sah wirklich, dass nichts durch App-
Namen oder durch Abenteuer oder andere durch
Zufall oder durch Zufall getan wird, sondern alles durch  die
vorhergesehene Weisheit Gottes, wenn es
in den Augen der Menschen Zufall ist, unsere Blindheit und
unser ungezwungener Blick als Ursache für die
Dinge, die in der zu
sagenden Weisheit Gottes von Anfang an sind, die er mit
Recht und Anbetung und
fortwährend zum Beth führt  und als
es dazu kommt, dass es uns plötzlich
selbst unwissend zufällt und so durch unsere
Blindheit in unserem unvorhersehbaren Blick, sagen wir, dass
diese Dinge zufällig und
zufällig sind,
also verstand ich es in der Liebesbekundung,
denn ich wusste genau, dass es in den Augen unseres Herrn
keine gibt  Zufall oder Zufall und
so gut wie die beste Tat getan wird und die
höchste so gut wie die geringste Tat getan wird
und in allem Eigentum und der Ordnung
, die unser Herr von
Anfang an bestimmt hat, denn es gibt keinen Handelnden
außer  er und hier ist eine andere Passage, es ist
wahr, dass die Sünde die Ursache all dieser Schmerzen ist,
aber alles wird gut, alle möglichen
Dinge sollen gut werden, es ist das berühmte
Ding, das die Leute immer aus Julian zitieren,
weil Gott es ihr in
einer der Visionen gesagt hat  Diese Worte wurden
liebevoll gezeigt und zeigten weder
mir noch niemandem die Schuld, dass sie in
Sicherheit sein wird. Dann war es eine große Unfreundlichkeit von
mir, Gott wegen meiner Sünde die Schuld zu geben oder sich über ihn zu wundern,
da er mich nicht für die Sünde verantwortlich macht, so
der Punkt  der ersten längeren Passage ist,
dass Gott alles vorhergesehen hat und
dann Gott
alles wegnimmt, so dass er
das Universum vorsorglich ordnet und nichts
ohne sein Mitspracherecht geschehen kann – also, wenn Sie so wollen,
mag es uns scheinen, dass es einige Dinge gibt
, die einfach zufällig passieren  oder durch Zufall,
aber tatsächlich gibt es keine Chance, dass
alles von Gott durch die Vorsehung bestimmt ist
, also ist die Idee des ersten
Abschnitts und die Idee des zweiten Abschnitts,
dass wir nicht darüber nachdenken
oder verzweifeln sollten, wir sollten nicht verzweifeln
über unsere Sünde, weil alles gut werden
soll, also hat Gott versprochen, dass wir erlöst werden, selbst wenn
wir sündigen
, also sieht es wieder so aus, als könnte es auf Zehenspitzen
in Richtung Ketzerei gehen, weil
wir nicht nur lehren sollen, dass wir es
können  aus eigener Kraft frei von Sünde sein,
wir sollten auch nicht lehren, dass
jeder richtig gerettet wird, also
wird es in der christlichen Theologie als selbstverständlich angesehen,
dass einige Menschen verdammt werden, andere
gerettet werden, und deshalb macht
sie diese Art von Vorbehalt  also lese ich
es noch einmal vor, also stelle ich den Text
wieder ein, damit du es sehen kannst. Sie sagt,
diese Worte seien ganz zärtlich gewesen
, ohne mir oder niemandem die Schuld zu geben,
dass sie in einem anderen sicher sein wird  Worte
die Menschen, die erlöst oder ins Paradies geschickt werden
, also hat sie diese sehr
optimistische Einstellung, und dann gibt es eine
Art Vorbehalt, ach ja, übrigens, einige
Menschen werden auch zur Hölle verdammt,
aber zu sagen, dass dies nicht der
Schwerpunkt ihrer Theologie ist  denken wou  Ich bin eine
Untertreibung, es ist wirklich eine Art Vorbehalt, der hin und wieder
auftaucht, und angesichts des Versprechens,
das Gott ihr in ihrer Vision gibt, dass alle
Finger gesund werden sollen, Gott soll
alles gut machen, vermuten Sie tatsächlich, dass
sie es irgendwie tut  möchte sagen, dass
am Ende alle gerettet werden, aber er achtet sehr
darauf, niemals etwas zu sagen, was
sie komplex über die Lehre
der Kirche weiß, und sie sagt das ausdrücklich,
also bekommt man immer diese kleinen
zusätzlichen Sätze, die das zeigen  Sie
beschränkt sich oft darauf, nur diejenigen zu unterrichten
, die
gerettet sind, aber manchmal kann man es mit
dieser Idee, den späteren
Protestantismus zu schwimmen, und in gewissem Maße in
Wickliffe, ihrem Zeitgenossen, den ich
zuvor erwähnt habe, sehr
deprimierend und irgendwie empfinden  des Eindrucks
davon richtig,
manche Leute sind gerettet, manche sind verdammt,
du weißt nicht, wer du bist, also bist du vielleicht
schon verdammt, und
du kannst als Ver nichts dagegen tun  Ein
irgendwie deprimierender Gedanke, es ist ein bisschen wie
eine Parodie oder eine
Art zu vereinfachte Darstellung dessen,
was sie sagen. Das ist sicherlich nicht das, was
Julian
sagt  Sie und aus ihrer
Sicht, dass die Frucht
aller Sünde tatsächlich Verzweiflung ist,
so weit entfernt ist sie von einigen dieser
anderen Autoren, die an der
Idee von Angst und Verzweiflung und Sehnsucht
unbefriedigter Sehnsucht festhalten  für Gott ist ihre Einstellung,
dass deine Art von Disposition
in Bezug auf Gott eine des
Vertrauens und sogar eine Art Annahme sein sollte, dass
er / sie
sich um dich kümmern wird, so wie du wie deine Mutter bist, also ist hier eine
Passage, wo sie das sagt  Gott zeigte
zwei Arten von Krankheit, die wir haben, eine
ist geduldig, ein Faulpelz, denn wir tragen unsere
Mühen und unseren Schmerz schwer, die andere
ist verzweifelt oder zweifelhaft, um einen Tropfen davon zu lesen
- mit anderen Worten, fürchten Sie im Allgemeinen, er
sollte wo sündigen  in allem ist alles verstanden,
aber in besonderen und anderen Worten
insbesondere hat er keine gezeigt, außer diesen beiden
, mit anderen Worten, die Wurzel aller Sünde oder
eine der beiden Wurzeln aller Sünde ist ein
Angstfaden, der so schreibt, dass Sie
am Ende nicht erlöst werden können  und dem
Schmerz nachzugeben, also möchte sie Ihnen sagen, dass sie
irgendwie beruhigend sein möchte und sie
, sagen wir, sie hat
diese Zeit des Leidens und der Angst
, die sie wegen ihrer Krankheit hat, irgendwie überstanden und
diese zutiefst optimistische Lehre als eine herausgebracht
Ergebnis dieser Vision, die sie hatte, in
der Gott verspricht, dass alles
gut werden wird, also ist hier eine andere Passage,
die sich darauf bezieht, die mit dieser Frage der Errettung zu tun hat,
denn wenn ich nur
auf mich selbst schaue, habe ich Recht, nicht mit
anderen Worten, ich habe  nichts als
überhaupt hoffe ich auf eine einzige
Barmherzigkeit mit allen meinen Mitchristen,
denn in dieser einen Hut endet also das
Leben aller Menschen, die für Gott gerettet werden sollen
, der alles so gut ist wie ich
sehe und Gott alles hat  T  er ist gemacht und
Gott liebt alles, was er gemacht hat, und
derjenige, der im Allgemeinen mit all seinen
Christen für Gott liebt, der alles liebt, was
für die Menschheit ist, die gerettet werden soll,
umfasst alles, das heißt alles,
was im Schöpfer von allem gemacht ist  ein fremder Verrückter
ist Gott und Gott ist alles, und
wer so liebt, liebt alles, also
bekommt man tatsächlich einen ziemlich klaren
Hinweis darauf, dass sie sich über
dieselben Dinge
Sorgen macht, um die
sich Wickliffe Sorgen gemacht hat  die
einzelne Person ist nichts, aber dann
wechselt sie sehr schnell die Perspektive zu
der Idee, dass, obwohl die
Christen eine Art Gemeinschaft sind
und sie alle zusammen gerettet und alle durch
Liebe miteinander verbunden sind, was ist mit den Verdammten, nun,
hier ist, was sie über den Schaden sagt
und diese sollen ohne Ende zur Hölle verdammt sein,
wie die Heilige Kirche mich lehrt zu
glauben, also hat sie wieder
irgendwie gut gespielt. Ich muss das sagen, weil es
mir irgendwie nicht erlaubt ist, es nicht zu
sagen  Und nachdem ich das alles verstanden hatte, hielt ich
es für unmöglich, dass
es unserer Lordschaft in dieser
Zeit gut gehen sollte, mit anderen Worten, sie macht sich Sorgen,
dass die Lehre der Kirche, dass
einige Menschen zur Hölle verdammt sind,
nicht mit dem vereinbar ist, was sie in ihr sah
Meine eigene Vision, und darauf hatte ich keine andere Antwort, zeigt unser Herr, aber das, was mir unmöglich ist, ist mir nicht unmöglich. Ich werde mein Wort bewahren
und alles, was
sie Ding gut nennen, und darin wurde ich
von der Gnade gelehrt  Gottes, dass ich
standhaft bleiben soll, sie halten mich im Glauben, wie ich
es zuvor verstanden hatte, also ist das eine
bemerkenswerte Passage. Ich denke, das kommt ungefähr
so nah wie sie zu sagen kommt, ich verstehe ni
ht wirklich, wie das funktionier
n wird, weil ich das weiß  Manc
e Menschen sollen zur Hölle verdammt sein,
aber schau, Gott hat mir gesagt, dass alles gut werden soll,
also denke ich, es wird sein, ich
weiß nur nicht wie, und es gibt verschiedene Arten
, das zu verstehen. Ich meine, es könnte sein,
dass die Menschen verdammt sind, aber es ist so  Okay
dass sie verdammt sind, vielleicht haben sie es verdient
, und so gehört es zum Guten
, dass manche Leute in die Hölle kommen und dort bleiben. Eine
andere Art, es zu nehmen, könnte sein, dass
sie in die Hölle kommen, aber sie wurden
am Ende für nicht so klar gehalten  aber es
zeigt plötzlich, wie weit sie in diese
Art von optimistischer Richtung geht, so dass sie
sogar bereit ist, mit
unorthodoxen Lehren zu flirten. Aufgrund
dieser Vision, die sie erhalten hat, gibt es
eine letzte Passage, die diese
Art von optimistischen Ideen mit der
allgemeineren Idee verbindet  von der Art der mystischen Vereinigung
mit Gott Gott ist nicht nichts als Güte,
unsere Seele hat eine - mit anderen Worten vereint
zehn unveränderliche Güte und zwischen
Gott und unserer Seele ist weder Zorn noch
Vergebung in seinen Augen, denn unsere Seele ist
irgendwie heilsam mit Gott vereint  von seiner
eigenen Güte, dass zwischen Gott und unserer
Seele vielleicht richtig ist, nicht mit anderen Worten,
zwischen ihm und uns ist nichts und es
ist nicht Verständnis, dass die Seele von
Liebe und Macht in jedem Shi war  Mit
anderen Worten, in jeder der
Visionen, die er hatte, ging es
darum, dass sie zusammengebracht wurde, um
Gott als Präsidentin mit Gott zu erleben
, um eine ganz bestimmte Botschaft zu erfahren
, nämlich Gottes Liebe, Gottes Güte, Gottes
Verheißung aller Dinge  soll gut
sein, das ist die treibende Kraft
ihrer gesamten Lehre, also ist es ein sehr
kraftvolles Buch und wie ich schon sagte, ein Buch,
das Ihnen in gewissem Maße etwas anderes erzählt als das,
was wir von anderen
Mystikern sogar aus der Umgebung und anderen weiblichen
Autoren hören, sogar zu Aramis
Zeiten  wie Katharina von Siena, das war so
ziemlich das, was ich über Julian sagen wollte,
bevor ich aufhöre, obwohl ich einen
Schritt zurücktreten und eine letzte Sache über
einige dieser mystischen Angebote sagen wollte, die
wir diskutiert haben, also sprach ich am
Anfang eines anderen  Vortrag darüber,
inwieweit Mystik
für die Philosophie relevant sein kann und Sie als Mystik
eine Art Philosophie kennen, sind die meses
Methoden, die sie sich ausgedacht haben, um
über Gott zu sprechen oder Gott zu begegnen bzw
Gott zu kennen,
sind sie alternative Methoden, die
Philosophie betreiben, oder sie sind tatsächlich
philosophische Theorien darüber, wie man
das Unerkennbare erkennt, wie man das Unsagbare sagt,
und ich stehe zu all dem, aber ich wollte
einen anderen Weg erwähnen, auf dem Fehlschläge
und Mystik für die Philosophie relevant sein könnten
und  ist etwas, worüber
zeitgenössische Philosophen viel nachgedacht haben,
eigentlich diese zeitgenössischen
Philosophen nicht wegen der Religion, und der
Grund, warum sie sagen, dass es vorerst gerettet
ist, ist, dass es für Julian besonders relevant ist,
also ist die Sache mit Julian, dass
ihre gesamte Lehre direkt auf
einigen basiert  Erfahrungen, die sie gemacht hat, und es ist
sehr klar, dass sie die Erfahrungen gemacht hat,
bevor sie verstand, was sie bedeuteten, also hat man
bei einigen dieser anderen Angebote im Garten
manchmal das Gefühl, dass
die Vision und das Verstehen einer
Vision vielleicht gleichzeitig gewährt werden
oder zumindest scheint es keine
große Lücke zu geben, aber im Fall von Julian ist das
Urteil mehr als das, was sie erhalten hat  diese
Visionen und sie hatte keine Ahnung,
was sie davon halten sollte, und sie dachte darüber nach und kam zu dem
, was hier als eine
Art maßgebliche Erklärung der
Visionen oder der Vorführungen präsentiert wird, also kann man aus
philosophischer Sicht fragen,
was wir tun sollten  aus religiösen
Erfahrungen wie dieser machen, also muss ich sagen, dass
ich noch nie eine religiöse Erfahrung gemacht
habe, vielleicht hast du, vielleicht hast du keine, aber
wir haben alle von Menschen gehört, die
religiöse Erfahrungen gemacht haben, auch wenn du
bis jetzt noch nie davon gehört hast  Sie haben gerade
von einem Julian aus Norwich gehört, aber
Sie haben mit ziemlicher Sicherheit schon von
anderen gehört.
Ich habe diese Erfahrungen gemacht, richtig, sie haben
Dinge gesehen, die wir vielleicht als
Halluzinationen betrachten, aber sie beschreiben sie als
weniger Sie wissen, dass Sie Jesus sehen oder
jemand anderen sehen  religiöse Figur oder
vielleicht nur diffuser die
Gegenwart Gottes erfahren oder was haben Sie oder ein
anderes Beispiel in wie den mittelalterlichen Figuren des Mittelalters
, die die
Stigmata direkt an einigen der Löcher in
den Händen erhalten haben und  Füße, die Christus erhielt,
also hatte Franz von Assisi das
mit ihm und Katharina von Siena,
das ist eine andere Art von religiöser
Erfahrung, und wie ich sage, Philosophie war eine
Religion, haben sich gefragt, was sie
davon halten sollen, denn im Allgemeinen, wenn andere Leute
berichten, etwas erlebt zu haben  Wir nehmen
das als guten Beweis dafür,
dass sie etwas erlebt haben, also war
ich zum Beispiel noch nie in Australien.
Ich hatte noch nie eine religiöse Erfahrung
und ich war noch nie in Australien, aber ich bin
jung, also würde ich es nicht wissen  Ich war also noch
nie in Australien, aber ich habe Leute
getroffen, die in Australien waren, und ihre
Erfahrungen mit Australien sind für mich ein guter
Beweis dafür, dass Australien existiert, und das
scheint ein Weg zu sein, auf dem wir ganz
bequem und natürlich argumentieren, wenn das so ist
Eine gute Art der Argumentation. Wenn wir also
bereit wären, ihre Erfahrungen mit
Australien als Beweis für die
Existenz Australiens zu nehmen, warum sollten wir dann nicht die
Beweise religiöser Erfahrungen
anderer Menschen als Evi betrachten?  Beweis für die
Existenz Gottes Sagen Sie jetzt vielleicht
gut, aber es gibt andere Ich meine den
Unterschied Recht zu tun, dass ich überprüfen kann, ob
ich selbst nach Australien
gehen kann  Erfahrungen als
Beweis richtig, also könntest du zum Beispiel
hier ein
einfacheres Beispiel haben, du
könntest eine sportliche Aktivität spielen und es
könnte die Frage sein, ob es
ein Foul gab und so wie hat Spieler he berührt
Spieler sein Spieler B sagt ich  wurde von
Spieler A berührt und jeder sagt, okay, wenn
du es gespürt hast. Ich bin sicher, er hat dich berührt
Aber wir erweitern das nicht auf religiöse
Erfahrungen und einige von uns waren eine
Religion, die wir denken sollten, also weisen sie
auf die lange Geschichte von Menschen mit
religiösen Erfahrungen hin, sie verweisen unter
anderen auf Julian  von Norwich und
sie sagen, sieh dir diese lebhaften, kraftvollen
Erfahrungen an, die diese Leute hatten, sie können nicht
alle nur verrückt gewesen sein, und tatsächlich
scheint sie nicht verrückt zu sein, also sollten
wir sie auf ihr Wort nehmen, dass sie
dies erlebt hat, und wir sollten es tun
Nehmen Sie es als etwas an, dass wir
unseren Glauben an die Existenz Gottes erhöhen sollten, mit
anderen Worten, es
macht es wahrscheinlicher oder plausibler,
dass Gott existiert. Andere Menschen wehren sich dagegen,
und einer der Gründe, warum Sie sich dagegen wehren
, ist, weil  Natürlich kommen diese religiösen
Erfahrungen nicht nur von
Christen, sondern auch von Menschen anderer
Religionen wie Juden, Muslimen, sehr
unterschiedlichen Religionen, so dass Menschen
religiöse Erfahrungen innerhalb des Hinduismus oder
Buddhismus oder Shinto oder was auch immer haben können, und das
bedeutet, dass wir Erfahrungen haben,
die anscheinend in eine andere Richtung weisen
Schlussfolgerungen
also hat der christliche Mystiker wie Julian
eine Erfahrung und das scheint ein
Beweis für den christlichen Gott und für
die Inkarnation Christi zu sein  Muslime
, die eine Gotteserfahrung haben, wie sagen wir,
Libyen hat eine Begegnung mit Gott, die
anscheinend ein Beweis für den Gott des Islam ist,
also können sie nicht beide Recht haben, also was
tun wir jetzt, was wir widersprüchliche
Beweise haben und da all diese religiösen
Erfahrungen im Widerspruch stehen  Auf
diese Weise sollten wir sie alle
abwerten, eine Antwort darauf ist, dass,
obwohl
die individuellen religiösen Erfahrungen
eines bestimmten Gläubigen nicht die
eigene Religion des Gläubigen unter
Ausschluss der anderen unterstützen, so dass Julian uns keine
Beweise dafür liefert  die Wahrheit des Christentums
könnte sie uns einen Beweis für die
Existenz des Göttlichen geben, denn vielleicht
zeigt sich das Göttliche verschiedenen
Menschen auf unterschiedliche Weise,
es zeigt sich auf die Weise,
die der Religion entspricht, in der
sie aufgewachsen sind, und so
weiter  Perennialismus, wie man es nennen
könnte, ist eine Art,
religiöse Erfahrung als Beweis für so
etwas wie die Realität des Göttlichen aufzubewahren.
Ich denke, es gibt ein Problem  Das ist, dass
jetzt, wo das Göttliche beginnt, so diffus zu werden,
dass es etwas ist, dem sogar
Atheisten zustimmen könnten, als ob
es nur so etwas wie die
Bedeutung des Lebens, das Wunder des
Universums bedeuten könnte, und in diesem Sinne könnte ein
Atheist tatsächlich ein Religiöses haben
Erfahrung richtig, so dass sie vielleicht sogar sagen,
oh, ich hatte letzten Sommer eine religiöse Erfahrung,
ich ging in die Berge und es
war so schön und ich war einfach
ehrfürchtig, aber ich habe Gott nicht erlebt, ich habe
nur die Majestät der Natur erlebt,
und wenn wir das sind.  Wenn wir darüber sprechen,
dann denke ich, dass es zu allgemein ist, um
für den Religionsstudenten oder den Religionsphilosophen von großem Interesse zu sein,
und der
letzte Gedanke dazu ist, dass
Sie tatsächlich viele Leute haben könnten, die
über Erfahrungen über etwas berichten
und an etwas glauben, ohne
diese  Erfahrungen und Überzeugungen, die
irgendeinen Bezug zur Wahrheit haben, selbst wenn
viele Leute sagen, dass sie glauben, dass
etwas wahr ist, oder behaupten, etwas zu erleben,
t  Das bedeutet nicht, dass es wahr ist, und ein
Beweis dafür ist, dass
Mittelalterliche im Allgemeinen, einschließlich
anscheinend mittelalterlicher Frauen, von dem, was
wir gesehen haben, voll und ganz der
Minderwertigkeit von Frauen verpflichtet waren und dachten, dass
sie es erfahren könnten, also trafen sie Männer, die
sie trafen  Frauen und sie berichteten
, dass Männer Frauen überlegen seien,
und das stimmt natürlich nicht, und
wir werden beim nächsten Mal mehr Beweise dafür bekommen
, dass das nicht stimmt, wenn wir uns
einige der mittelalterlichen Debatten über die
Unterlegenheit von Frauen oder die Gleichberechtigung von
Frauen ansehen  und sehen Sie einige
Autoren, die sich gegen frauenfeindliche
Tendenzen in der mittelalterlichen Kultur ausgesprochen haben, darunter
eine ganz besondere Autorin, deren Name
Christine de Pizan ist, und sie wird im
Mittelpunkt des letzten Vortrags dieser Reihe stehen.
Ich hoffe, Sie schließen sich mir dafür an. Danke